[موسيقى]
مساء الخير عصر عن قرب وهجر وقوه الصحوه
في السعوديه في الثمانينيات والتسعينيات
الميلاد
وصاحبه تجربه اداريه طويله في العمل
الحكومي الماني
تحدث فيه عن تجربته الشخصيه بمعايشه
الحركات الاسلاميه ورموزها في السعوديه
منذ ان كان طالبا في المرحله المتوسطه
نائب وزير الشؤون الاسلاميه
دكتور خليني ابدا معك من كتابك تشخيص الصح
وتحليل وذكريات هذا الكتاب صدر في 2018
لكنك عدت طباعه هذا الكتاب في 2022 هذا
العام
لماذا عاد طباعه او شل يشجعك على اعاده
طباعته اولا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اولا
الحقيقه الطبعه الاولى نفذت يعني خلال
يعني الاسبوع الاول في معرض الكتاب لما
اعرض همم لم يبقى منها شيء فكان هناك كثير
الحقيقه من بعض المحبين وبعض المهتمين همم
بهذا الموضوع لاعاده طباعته مره اخرى همم
هذا الامر الحقيقي يشجعني على اعاده
الطباعه
واتاحته همم عدد اكبر من المهتمين
والمختصين وليكن ايضا همم يعني مساهمه في
التوعيه من خطر همم تنظيمات الحركيه
والصحه والحركيه التي
هينا منها عقود من الزمن
دكتور لو سالتك اليوم بعد تحليل همم يعني
تجربه ذكريات مرتبها ايضا مع الحركات
الاسلاميه السياسي والصح والتحديد في
السعوديه
لو سالتك بماذا يعرف ت- توفيق سدير الاطار
الفلسفي لحركات الاسلاميه
المنطلق الفلسفي والفكري للحركات همم
الاسلام ما يسمى بحركات الاسلاميه
حركات التفسير السياسي للاسلام هي بدات
منذ وقت مبكر بدات على يد رجلين احدهما في
المشرق همم
العراءه في المشرق الاسلامي همم في الهند
على يد همم سيد احمد خان واا ثم تلميذه
محمد اقبال في ال همم منطقتنا نشا على يد
جمال الدين الافغاني همم كانت الف وهي
تبني التفسير المصلحي همم للدين
وكان ذلك في همم نهايه او بدايه سقوط
السلطنه همم العثمانيه همم طرحت فكره
انشاء الجامعه الاسلاميه التي طرحها جمال
الدين الافغاني اا في الهند ايضا همم سيد
احمد خان قال له طرح مماثل همم نظرا
لاحتكاك بالفلسفات الاوروبيه وكذا فخلط
بين ما يريده اصلاحا وبين هذه النظريات
بقي هذا الفكر همم مجرد فكر بين المخب واا
في عام
1928 همم
حرك هذا
الامر ونفخه في الروح حسن البنا في مصر
وكذلك في بشكل شبه متزامن والاعلى الموجود
في القاره الهنديه فهنا نشات ال ال
الحركات همم الاسلاميه همم التي تتبنى
التفسير السياسي لاسلام تفسير السياسي
يعني همم
الهدف
مصلحي ونافعي وان
سياسي بالدرجه الاولى الغايه في الاسلام
هي اقامه الحكم هنا وهنا مكمان همم
الخطوره
وبالتالي همم هذا مخالفه لانهاج الرباني
وهو تعبير الناس اللي رب العالمين الاصل
في ذلك العباده يعني اللي همم وياتي
التمكين والحكومه لذلك اشياء تابعه حسب
همم لذلك الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول الذين
امكنهم في الارض همم فقال هنا في اشتراك
ان همم فليس التمكين ضروري المهم هو همم
عباده الله سبحانه وتعالى واصال هذا الى
الناس هؤلاء لا همم يعني جعلوا السياسه
اصل وان الوصول الحكم وما يسميه المودود
وتبعه سيد قطب همم غيره بالانقلاب همم
السياسي للوصول الى سده الحكم ثم التغيير
طبعا نتج ان هذا الفكر او هذه الفلسفه ااه
تكفير المجتمعات الاسلاميه وهمم
تكفير الحكومات والحكام وعدم شرعيتهم
والخروج عليهم تقول همم في الكتاب همم
عرفتوا عن بعد وتبات الحراك الفكر السابق
لجيلي
الذي كان متوهجا قبل حرب 67 لكني لم
اعايشه لاسباب اهمها المرحله العمريه
وكذلك كون نشات في محيط محافظ وبيئه دينيه
مواليه بعمق الهويه والدوله السعوديه
ولذلك قد لا استطيع الكتابه كما اكتب عن
حراك الفكري الحركي الاسلامي السياسي
لانني عيشت هذا الاخر في المدرسه
ما هي هذه الظروف برايك اليوم بعد دراستك
لهذه الظاهره التي ساهمت في همم نشاه
وتغلغل الحركات الاسلاميه
[موسيقى]
همم الفكر الحركي همم قدم الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في وقت مبكر جدا يعني
حتى يمكننا ان نقول ان اول تنظيم للاخوان
المسلمين في المملكه العربيه السعوديه كان
عام
1937 للميلاد يعني بعد انشاء جماعه
الاخوان في مصر همم تسع سنوات تقريبا همم
طبعا حسن البنا عندما كان ياتي الى موسم
الحج همم يعني عامل على انشاء هذا التنظيم
همم طبعا بشكل غير معلن همم حاول جنس نبض
همم
همم المملكه العربيه السعوديه من خلال
طرحها على الملك عبد العزيز رحمه الله همم
فكره انشاء فرع للاخوان ورد عليه الملك
عبد العزيز غفر الله له برد حاسم في هذا
الموضوع ااه ثم ااه يعني توالى النشاط هذه
الجماعات لكن لم يكن لها بريق لدى
المثقفين ولدنب همم وذلك ل- اا ان ال- ال-
الوهج في ذلك الوقت كان همم تيارات
القوميه واليساريه وهمم شيوعي والبعث
والناصر والقومي وما الى ذلك هذا الوجه
كان مستمر في الخمسينات الاربعينات
الخمسينات الستينات حتى عام 1967 وهو
مرحله انكسار هذا المد فاستغل الحركيون
الاسلام الامويون همم في طبعا في العالم
كله ومن بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه هذا
الامر وب وبناء القواعد الشعبيه لهم
ابتداء من عام تقريبا همم 67 بدا النشاط
الفعلي الحركي في قطاعات التعليم في
المدارس كانت الاساس او الخطه او البدايه
في التوغل او الهدف وقطاع التعليم
عن المدارس المدارس
[موسيقى]
السياسيه والعسكريه
وهنا بدات الانطلاقه
لكن بعد ذلك كما قلت توسعت ودخلت الى
قطاعات مختلفه وكان الاهتمام ربما كما قلت
اساسا في قطاع الثالث
لتوغل هذه الجماعات في قطاع التعليم الى
اي حد
اصبحوا متنفذين ومتولين او متحكمين في
المؤسسه التعليميه في السعوديه
درجه كبيره جدا طبعا في البدايه كانت
بدايه ضعيفه واا مقاومه لا يعني ما كان
المجتمع همم معتاده على همم العمل الحركي
النشاطات الحركيه كانت غريبه يعني في
المدارس وفي همم لكنهم شيئا فشيئا همم
استثمر همم النشاط اللاصفي في همم المدارس
والجمعيات كان جمعيه الكشافه جواله في
الجامعات همم جمعيات التوعيه الاسلاميه
الاذاعه المدرسيه المسرح كل شيء بداوا
يستفيدوا منها ومن خلالها يوجهون
ويستقبون في نفس الوقت همم الطلاب الى همم
جماعاتهم بمخ التنظيمات التي كانت تلعب في
الساحه في ذلك الوقت
حجم تاثيرهم الى اي مدى وصل برايك في
التعليم يعني في ذلك الوقت او ان ان ذلك
الوقت هم بعد ذلك ما هي النتائج تاثير
بالذات في فتره نهايه السبعينات
والثمانينات والتسعينيات بكاملها كان
تاثير واكتساح قوي لهم في القطاع التاليه
مش ملامح هذا التاثير يعني اللي ظهرت على
ارض الواقع برايه الملامح ما رايناه من
همم فكر التطرف فكر التشدد طبعا انا افرق
بين التطرف والتشدد ولكن هذا موجود وشبينه
مش بينهم الفرق التطرف همم يعني يكون
نتيجه لعمل حزبي منظم يصل بالفرد او
التابع لهذه الجماعه الى همم اعمال اقوال
او اعمال همم متطرفه او ارهابيه التشدد لا
التشدد قد يكون في مسائل دينيه معينه مساء
الفل مساء الكذا وليس بالضروره ان يكون
المتشدد همم تابع لايدلوجيه معينه او الى
تنظيم معين او الى حزم معين هذا الفرق
بينهما همم بلا شك انهم همم اكتسحوا واثر
على المجتمع والنتيجه ما راينا خلال فتره
التسعينات من الافكار التصرف التي اليها
في قضايا التفجير وقضايا التكفير
خروج على الدوله وعلى النظام همم سواء في
المملكه او في غيرها يعني خلينا نتوقف معك
الفيصل قصيره عود بعد المتابعه والنقاش
معك دكتور توفيق فاصل القصيم مشاهدينا
نعود بعده للسؤال مباشر
اهلا بكم من جديد
الشؤون الاسلاميه
يعني حتى حتى ربما نشير الى بعض الاماكن
المهمه والنقاط المهمه في هذا الكتاب من
خلال رصدك
وتشخيصك لهذه الحاله الظاهره ما هي اهم
فروع وتقسيمات هذه الجماعه
الجماعات الاسلاميه السياسي الموجوده في
السعوديه
والفرق بين قوه تاثيرها بالمقارنه بينها
يعني همم كما ذكرت قبل قليل البدايه
البذره الاولى للتنظيم الاخوان المسلمين
بالذات كان عام 1937 وكان في همم منطقتين
مكه المكرمه والمدينه المنوره
الحجاز لم ااه يعني يسجل بشكل رسمي او
يرتبط بشكل رسمي الا في بدايه الثمانينات
الميلاديه لكن هذا يعني انه لا لم يكن
هناك عمل حزبي تنظيمي في المنطقه
فتقسيمات الاخوان همم في المملكه كما
رصدتها انا اولا اخوان الحجاز وتشمل منطقه
مكه المكرمه المدينه المنوره مدينه جده
الطائف ينبع همم تبوك وعسير وجازان
والباحه وبعض منتسبي لتنظيم في المنطقه
الشرقيه يتبعون لاخوان الحجاز او تنظيم
الحجاز حتى في الشرقيه نعم جزء منهم همم
علاقات شخصيه وكذا قد يكون ذهبوا بحكم
الدراسه في الجامعات والمنطقه الشرقيه
تفرق في الارتباط هم يرتبطون الكل يرتبط
بتنظيم العام يعني لكن لكل تنظيم مراقب
مسؤول عنه وله مجلس الشورى مستقل همم
يتعاونوا فيما بينهم لكن لهم مرجعيه خارج
المملكه ال- همم التنظيم
يعني هو اخوان همم الزبير وهمم الاخلاق
الحميد من من العراق الذين استعدوا
الجنسيه وهؤلاء ارتباطهم
همم تنظيم اخوان الكويت ارتباطهم الهرمي
التنظيم
القسم الثالث لهم اخوان الرياض
وهؤلاء طبعا انشقوا الى قسمين همم
تنظيم اخوان الرياض انفرد بمجموعه وشك في
تنظيم مستقل صغير ركز فيها على مناشه
معينه همم كل همم يعني نشاط الجواله في
الجامعات وكذا وبقي التنظيم الرئيسي همم
عفوا الاسماء يعني
ذكرت رموز همم لانه ليس من المهم ان نرصد
الفكر والحركه يعني همم
انشقت عن المجموعه فاصبح تنظيم الرياض
تنظيم بيننا يعني ال- همم التنظيم الخامس
اللي هو اخوان الشرقي
وهؤلاء يعني يعني مستقلون في
تنظيم مستقل ااا ومرتبطون ايضا تنظيميا
هرميا باخوان الكويت كان اوج نشاط الاخوان
تنظيم العام بهذا التنظيمات الخمسه
ما بين عام 1967 الى عام 1991 كانت
قواعدهم كبيره ومكتسحه طبعا تنظيم السروري
نشا تقريبا عام
65 عندما قدم محمد سرور الى المملكه لكن
كان مستضعف
وبدايه وكانت ضعيفه لدرجه انه كان محارب
من قيادات التنظيم همم جلسنا في حال مدرس
او اداري في همم تبع وزاره المعارف ويحدى
المدارس ثم سنه في معهد البكيريه العلميه
ثم سنه في معهد همم
همم ثم اربع سنوات في معهد بريده ثم انتقل
للاحساء لمده سنتين حتى رحل عن المملكه
عام 1970 طبعا كان همم وجود فتره وجوده في
همم حائل وفي القصيم كان مناع القطان ايضا
في معهد عنيزه وكان محمد العبده السوري
ايضا من التنظيم العام في معهد الرس وطبعا
صار بينهم اعداء لان همم محمد سرور خالفهم
وبدا يعمل بشكل مستقل فاصبحوا يكيدون له
وهم سبب تنقلاته
ثم ابعاده فيما بعد حيث وشوا به الى
الدوله محمد سرور انتقل للكويت اعمل في
مجله همم المجتمع همم تقريبا حتى عام 76
همم من 73 الى 76 ثم بعدها انتقل المدرس
في ثانويه عبد الله السالم في الكويت وبعد
ذلك همم انتقل همم او اخرج من الكويت
انتقل الى برمجهام في بريطانيا واسس مجله
السنه التي كان يهاجم فيها طبعا من ضمن ما
يكتب المملكه العربيه السعوديه وعلمائها
ودعاءاتها وكان اوجه ذلك في اثناء حرب همم
تحرير الكويت ااه طبعا بعد عام 91 بدات
تنظيم السروري باكتساح القواعد سواء في
المدارس او في الجامعات او في همم يعني
واصبحوا اكثر
وهنا اريد ان اعود الى ما قاله الامير
محمد بن سلمان لصحيفه التايم الامريكي في
حديث مهم شهيره ايضا قال بان تنظيم جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين هو الاب الشرعيه لجميع
الحركات والتنظيمات التي انتشرت في العالم
لكنه وصف اتباع السروريه بانهم الاكثر
تتطرفا في الشرق الاوسط وانهم اعلى درجه
من جماعات همم الاخوان المسلمين لماذا همم
الاخوان التنظيم العام همم اكثر تلون
واكثر ثم لهم لم يعد لهم قبول بالذات في
المملكه وفي دول الخليج لم يعد لهم ذاك
القبول الاخوان التنظيم العام السروريون
لا يعني محمد سرور كان ذكي لانه عرف
التوجه الديني والمدرسه الدينيه في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه فلعب على هذا
الوتر فخلط بين السلفيه وما بين الفكر
الاخواني بالتالي اجتذب الشباب اليه وشكل
هذه القاعده الكبيره همم المشكله في تنظيم
السروري ايضا انه همم من ضمن ادبياته تبني
تكفير طبعا كل حتى الاخوان همم مالات
فكرهم ينتهي الى التكفير لكن محمد سرور
والسروريون همم يعني قام فكرهم على تكفير
الدوله
وتكفير همم المجتمعات طبعا صار بينهم
خلافات في هذا فيما بعد لكن هذا شيء متاصل
همم لديهم ومن هنا تاتي همم خطوره هذا
التنظيم
اضف الى ذلك انه يخدع الناس بانه تنظيم
سلفي
بحكم ما خلطه من السلفيه ومن همم فكر
الاخوان المسلمين وبالتالي قد ينطلي على
الكثير من الناس بعض الاشخاص وبعض الرموز
المنتمين لهذا التنظيم
يعني يخدعون به
ولذلك شكل قاعده كبيره
اكبر من قاعده جماعه الاخوان في داخل
المملكه اعتقد اعتقد الان ان اتباع
السروريه همم هم الاغلب في همم الكوادر
الشباب
وكوادر همم مظهرهم مختلف دكتور
عفوا السروريون همم
همم يعني لا يختلف مظاهرهم الاخوان قد
يكون لديهم ما عنده مشكله في تغيير المظهر
في ان يتماشى مع اي مجتمع مع اي شكل لكن
السرورين لا اضافه الى همم نقطه اخرى في
سروريون وهي التشدد في بعض المسائل
الفكريه الفقهيه وبعض الامور المجتمعيه
همم اكثر من الاخوان
فلذلك نرى المعارضات التي تمت همم حملات
الاحتساب التي همم رايناها في قبل عشر
سنوات او 15 سنه همم هذه كان قوامها في
الاغلب من اتباع التنظيم السروري
دكتور اليوم ما هو وضع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه امام هذه التيارات يعني
خصصنا حلقات متعدده
للمناقشه في الحركات الاسلاميه وفي حجم
توجولات المجتمع السعودي لنطرح سؤال يمكن
قررنا لك اكثر من ضعيف هناك كتاب مثل خالد
العباد وعبد الله بجاد العتيبي واخرين كثر
ما زالوا يحذرون من خطوره هذه الحركه ما
زالوا يحذرون من خطوره همم وهم ضد ما يقال
همم بموت الصحوه او انتهاءها بعد حركه
التغيير اللي بدات المملكه العربيه
السعوديه يمكن على كل المستويات الى اي
مدى بالفعل نحن امام همم خطر لعوده الصحوه
مره اخرى او عوده هذه الحركه مرتين وفي اي
وقت ممكن ان يحدث ذلك
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بقياده همم خادم
الحرمين الشريف بين الملك سلمان حفظه الله
ومعارضته ومسانده همم ولي عهده صاحب السمو
الملكي الامير محمد بلا شك ان ما حدث همم
في هذا العهد من يعني حزم حزم
ويعني قطع يدبر هذه التنظيمات همم عمل همم
مع عمل في ممكن اربع او خمس سنوات يوازي
عمل 40 او 50 سنه همم بلا شك انه قلل من
خطرها همم اصبحوا يتوارلون لكن نقطه مهمه
وهي ان الصحوه همم جذورها وهمم هناك جمر
تحت الرماد ما زال ومن طبيعه هذه
التنظيمات انهم في مرحله همم الضغط والحزم
انهم يكمنون حتى تتاح لهم الفرصه الدليل
همم هذا الفكر كما اساس الفلسفي يمكن قبل
اكثر من 150 سنه
يعني على يد سيد احمد خان ومحمد اقبال ثم
جمال الدين الافغاني حتى جاء حسن البنا
والموجودي واحيو هذا الفكر مرت الحركات
سواء في المشرق العربي او في
الدول الاخرى في العالم الاسلامي مرت
يعني انكسارات ولكن مع ذلك تعود فهي تعود
وتتشكل وتلون لذلك يجب ان يبقى على حذر من
هذه التنظيمات وافكارها وتسللها هي تتشكل
يعني كانت تركز على ميادين معينه الان هي
تدخل في ميادين الاخرى مثلا همم السوشال
ميديا ميدان الجمعيات او المؤسسات المجتمع
المدني همم
كل هذه
همم اصبحوا ينفذون من خلالها وان بشكل غير
مباشر طيب بالنسبه للقطاعات اللي كانوا
متوغلين فيها يعني انت سميت عدد من
القطاعات هناك حتى العسكريه السياسيه
تعليميه اقتصاديه ربما الاعلام
هل مازالوا موجودين ما زال موجودين لكن
بدرجه اقل بدرجه كبيره جدا جدا يعني
بالذات يعني القطاعات الحساسه الامنيه
والسياسيه بدرجه كبيره جدا همم يكاد يكون
وتلاجه لكن قطع التعليم ما زال ما زال في
بواقي لان القطاع عريض جدا المؤسسه
الدينيه ايش المشكله ليش ما احنا نقدر هذا
الفكر من جذوره كما ذكرت يعني هل هناك
يعني ربما اختلاف في مساله المنهجيه
للمواجهه بين جهات وقطاعات عدم تبني
استراتيجيه موحده ربما لمواجهه هذا الفكر
ما زالت مفقوده الى الان
اولا
ما بني في 80 سنه او بالتحديد عندنا هنا
يمكن 50 او 60 سنه
من طبائع الامور
كذلك ما اشرت اليه
لابد ان يكون لدينا استراتيجيه وطنيه
تلتزم بها كافه القطاعات الحكوميه وهمم
هناك او في تباين بينهم
وتوجيهات عليا تحسم الامور لكن مع الاسف
يعني ما زالت بعض الجهات همم يعني لا اقول
متراقيه لكن غير مقدره همم لا اعذرني من
ال همم لكن ما زالت بعض الجهات غير مقدره
لخطوره همم رموز هذه الجماعات وخطوره هذا
الفكر بالتالي يلزمنا استراتيجيه وطنيه
نلتزم بها جميعا ليس فقط القطاعات
الحكوميه حتى قطاعات همم
القطاع الخاص القطاع الخيري او القطاع
الثالث كلها لابد ان همم تلتزم بهذه
الاستراتيجيه دكتور اشكرك شكرا جزيل على
تواجدك معي ذكرت تريد ان تضيف هذه الاضافه
الاخيره التي اود ان اضيفها ان جماعات
التفسير السياسي الاسلام الاخوان
والسروريه وغيرهم همم الحقيقه انهم ضد
دوله المواطنه
والدوله الوطنيه لماذا لانها همم دوله
تدعو الى ارساء السلم المجتمعي التسامح
نبذ الكراهيه همم هؤلاء افعالهم ومالات ما
قاموا به ضرب السلم الاجتماعي ونشر همم
يعني ثقافه الكراهيه الحقيقه ان سمو ولي
العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان له دور كبير
في مكافحه سواء همم التطرف الفساد وهذا
الفساد الفكري همم من اخطر انواع فساد ف-
همم يعني سعى الى نشر ثقافه التعايش وهمم
السلام والتسامح داخليا واقليميا ودوليا
اشكرك شكرا جزيل دكتور توفيق سديري نائب
وزير الشؤون الاسلاميه الاسباب شكرا لك
على تواجدك شكرا لكم ونتمنى ان نلتقي ان
شاء الله بمناسبات اخرى من سؤال مباشر
على تويتر فيسبوك يوتيوب
اليها على شاهد وعلى العربيه